الى الجيش
والتحقيقات الانفجار يوم امس وقع باطلاق
روسيا مجموعه كبيره من الهجمات الصاروخيه
على اوكرانيا
ومنذ بدايه الحرب غير شرعيه الروسيه على
اوكرانيا زادت النيته حضرها في المنطقه
الشرقيه
وبمراقبه الوضع على هذه النساء
الناس الجيش انسان
نيسان
الجويه
الاوكرانيه التي تحمي اراضيها من هجمات
صواريخ الكروز الروسيه لكن دعوني اكون
واضحه
اوكرانيا
بلروسيا تحمل
المسؤوليه كامله مع استمرار الشرعيه
والمتضامنين مع بولندا ونواصل دعمنا
لاوكرانيا في حقها للدفاع عن النفس ان
روسيا عليها وقف هذه الحرب غير المبرره
ليله امس تحدثت
والرئيس الامريكي
ميتسوبيشي ستبقى متحده ودائما سنقوم بما
يستلزم الدفاع عن جميع الحلفاء بهذا انا
مستعد لتلقي اسئلتكم
سؤال من الاذاعه البولنديه
سيد الامين العام ماذا يمكن ان تكون
النتيجه
لهذا الاجتماع
الله يسعدك برستيشن 2
ناقشنا التضامن والتكافل مع حليفنا بولندا
وعربنا عن بالغ تعزينا على همم
لاسر الضحايا وزدنا وجودنا في الجزء
الشرقي من التحالف منذ
الغزو لاوكرانيا في فبراير لدينا المزيد
من القوات البريه
بحرينيه
وزدنا قدراتنا الدفاعيه الجويه وكذلك
قدراتنا
[موسيقى]
تصور كامل
وجودنا في المنطقه الشرقيه من التحالف
شكرا سؤال سؤال
ليله امس هل تعتقد ان هذه
الشده
النقاط التي يحتك فيها الناتو في هذا
الصراع منذ بدايته
دائما
للحوادث لان هذا يعني يوضح ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا وهي مسؤوليه الرئيس
روسيا مجموعه كبيره بدنا صواريخ على المدن
الاوكرانيه التي استهدفت المدنيين والبنا
تحتيه واستهداف المواقع المدنيه
[موسيقى]
كما نرى
انه سيكون هناك طبيعات على الاراضي اراضي
دول الناتو تبعات بسبب الحرب التي تشنها
روسيا على اوكرانيا
ننتقل الى وكاله الانباء الاوكرانيه
الشعب البولندي سؤال كيف لهذه الحادثه ان
تنعكس على المساعدات
التي يقدمها الحلفاء اللي اوكرانيا في
الدفاع الجوي هل سيكون هناك دفعات جويه
اضافيه جديده لحمايه الاجواء الاخرانيات
لقاء اليوم في مجموعه الاتصال الخاصه
باوكرانيا
ستبحث ضروره دعم همم قوه الاوكرانيا
بس بس دائما على الدفاعات الجويه
خاصه في اعقاب بدا روسيا لاطلاقها هذه
الصواريخ العشوائيه على المدن الاوكرانيه
مع عدد اضافي من الدول التحالف الذين
يناقشون
البطاريات من اسبانيا والسويد اعلنت عن
المساعدات همم في الدفاعات الجويه
لاوكرانيا وغيرهم نحن نقوم بتعبئه عامه
للمساعدات خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالدفاعات الجويه وكذلك
عام الحزن الاجتماعي
صوت طبيعه جدا اما من مؤشرات على ان
الضربات الصاروخيه كانت متعمده والنات
تكثف اجراءاته الاحترازيه في الشرق بعد
الهجوم في بولندا وروسيا تتحمل كامل
المسؤوليه وليس اوكرانيه يقول ايضا الامير
العام لحزب الناتو ان التحليلات الاوليه
تشير الى ان الهجوم تم بصوارخ دفاعيه
اوكرانيه ودفعنا بالمزيد من القوات البريه
والبحريه في الجناح الشرقيه
الصواريخ الروسيه